nach diversen pannen bei der
abgeordnetenhauswahl in berlin am 26
september wer die landeswahlleitung beim
verfassungsgerichtshof einspruch gegen
das wahlergebnis einlegen
das können nicht landeswahlleiterin
petra michaelis nach den beratungen des
landeswahlausschusses an in zwei
wahlkreisen habe es verstöße gegen
rechtliche bestimmungen gegeben die
auswirkungen auf die mandatsverteilung
haben könnten bei der wahl am 26
september gingen in einigen berliner
wahllokalen die stimmzettel aus in
anderen lagen zunächst die falschen aus
vor manchen wahl orten bildeten sich
lange schlangen so dass manche wähler
erst nach 18 uhr ihre stimme abgeben
konnten
landeswahlleiterin michaelis hatte
deshalb ihren rücktritt angekündigt sie
hatte den senat gebeten sie nach der
sitzung des landeswahlausschusses an
diesem donnerstag unverzüglich
abzuberufen